this film had an after the credit scene
and this was released back in 2005. the
way you guys did it was well before the
mcu
with iron man in 2008 i'm curious how
did you end up with the after the credit
scene
and was there any pressure to not
include it you know like
because it wasn't the norm like it is
now with so many movies with after the
credit scenes
the after the credit scene was akiva's
idea um
which i thought was very cool and one of
the reasons and that was not part of our
initial shoot it wasn't part of our sort
of initial photography
after we had that screening of that
sizzle reel and we got the studio really
excited
akiva and i kind of went back to them
and said hey guys now that you're
excited you know there's a couple of
other things we want to do i'd really
love to reshoot this club sequence
and we'd really love to do this thing at
the end uh
after the credits akiba has this idea
and they said great go ahead and they
gave us you know a decent amount
of money to go get additional footage
um but yeah that was all that was
akiva's idea
there's not a lot of explanation about
anything
so it was a way of closing that story
uh opening up other stories should we
ever have gotten to do them
um you know just again in a certain way
that made sense to us
was relatively oblique compared to how
things are typically laid out but it was
fun